cal cuatro he uh
did a really nice job in his last start
against the white sox
one on one out and the one two to colin
moran swing gonna miss he couldn't hit
that if he had a stepladder
rarely see a swing at pitches like that
but he gets the strikeout and once again
he's in this first inning he's thrown
nine pitches and eight of them have been
strikes
now josh bell right back to quantrill
who made a terrific
leaping grab and cal cuantro has a 12th
kit jenny
and that's good news a.t brubacher he
looks to
finish strong and continue this great
stretch
by the starting pitchers indians have
two on and scoring position here against
jt brubacher
and he strikes out reyes and the threat
brian reynolds to lead off for
pittsburgh cal cuatro the 2-1 pitch and
reynolds with a one-hopper oh and a
diving step by lindor
and the throw to first got him that is a
spectacular
play by francisco lindor just to catch
it just to stop it because it took a
wicked
big hop i think they may check this one
though he looks safe to me that was a
tremendous play
but that's where you should hit the bag
with that toe is the very front part so
it's going to be quick
and he's safe but that was a still an
outstanding effort by lindor
[Music]
oh here's the pitches in the air to
right shallow and that's going to drop
in for a hit
and here comes riddle to score and the
pirates lead one nothing
as jose osuna drops a single into right
field following the e3
one nothing pittsburgh one ball one
strike pitch
bouncing ball short gonzalez throws to
second for one on to first and a double
play
cleans it up no argument there close
play
six four three first walk by brubacher
brings up oscar mercardo
and that time with the fastball gets the
strikeout
to ending in it one down and here is key
brian hayes
certainly have for hayes who sends one
out to center it's caring
and it's got a home run eight straight
hits
for key brian hayes he's just hovered
absolutely incredible they're bowled
over
he's just done everything he is all over
it
miranda's last at-bat so i'm gonna pitch
above his eyes
so that's the second strikeout for cal
cuatro and there are
two down here in the third indians down
two to nothing
runner at second base two down here in
the third
santana smokes it deep center field
she is gone and the indians have tied
the game
oh man did he absolutely destroy that
baseball
santana is two for two and we are tied
at two
in the third well he's certainly put a
good swing on that baseball
perez walked in the second oh there's
one out
there's three ops there's the other
cam hill second reliever comes in
well this team can win some games and
they can play some clean baseball games
and they can do some things with the bat
as well
and there's a home run for osuna who has
gotten hot toward the end here as well
and now he's got his fourth home run
what's the pulp pen gonna do
all right it's sunday right jose osuna
gives the bucks the 3-2 lead in the
fifth inning they have two on one out
fifth inning they just walked the
indians just walked keep brian hayes
intentionally to face to colin moran
so left on left moran against perez
follow the right side
a four six oh it would have been a
double play had lindor thrown a strike
to santana instead he throws it past the
first baseman
and the pirates will get a run out of it
frazier scores it 4-2
and now jose osuna who has singled in
homered
three-hit day for osuna
riddle on the move held at third
on that ripping double by jose so now
a home run a double and a single today
the bases
are loaded out to right
and luplow can't get there it's to the
wall
riddle is in and osuna will score
another double for frazier
brings in two bucks up 6-2 ron milray is
coming to the plate with two on and
nobody out
in the air center field and deep
reynolds back he's out of room it's out
of here and the indians come roaring
right back it's a one-run
game oh frontmail reyes did he ever need
one of those
his ninth home run of the year look at
the big man
fired up so there's a start here to the
seven and here comes that man again jose
ramirez
and he pops it to center field back goes
reynolds still going back
leaps up and can't make the play
hernandez
will round second he's going to be
forced to go to third because ramirez
had run right up his back
jose almost passed him at first base
that was very close
because cesar thought reynolds was going
to catch the ball
he was going back to first base and that
ball just kept going
tying run 90 feet away but santana line
drive right field that is going to get
down and that's going to go to the wall
the indians take the lead carlos santana
with his third hit of the day
his fourth run batted in of the
afternoon
and the indians are up seven to six and
now the big man who started to come back
with one big swing in the sixth inning
get it done pops in the air to deep
center reynolds
will settle under it santana will tag
pete comes home to score and the indians
have scored three times in the seventh
and lead it now
eight to six pirates down to their last
out josh bell will be the better
right field long run for luplow
he makes the catch and that'll do it the
indians win the series
they take the rubber game from
pittsburgh and come from behind fashion
winning it eight
to six